- Grab the longer one,
just pull it to your hook.
- Yeah.
- Got it.
- Huh. Cool.
- Oh, like you pull it like that.
- Yeah. I'll just quickly
finish up this one.
- Oh check it- oh- what!
Oh my gosh, do you just sit there
and watch TV and do that?
Like it's something like, you...
- Yeah.
(applause)
- Oh my gosh!
- Finished!
(applause)
- This one's mine.
- Mine just seemed to
slip out of my hands-
- It's not that hard, guys.
- And fell down.
- It's not that hard guys!
(laughter)
- All right, well, Jonah, I heard that
you brought us some gifts,
which is very sweet.
Do you want to show us?
- Yes I would!
- Okay, I heard from a
birdie- a little birdie.
I really want to keep
this, can I keep this?
- Okay, so...
- (gasps) I hope one is mine,
- The second-
- I don't know what's gonna be mine.
- No peeking yet!
- My daughter's gonna die
if one of them's mine.
- Starting off with a hat for Cedric.
- All right...
- All right!
- Nice, man!
- Beautiful.
- I made a scarf for you, Mindy,
- Thank you!
- in beautiful ocean colors.
(applause)
- And then for you, Danica, I made
a pair of fingerless gloves.
- Oh, that's nice!
- I made them fingerless since yarn
doesn't make good racing gloves, so...
- No!
- What- what about that green and gold
thing you got in there?
- Oh, well, first, I gotta finish
the gift for you
(laughter)
- I thought this was
like a white elephant.
- A matching headband.
- You trade out
- That's beautiful, thank you!
- That's awesome, dude!
- And also, I just happened to make
a Packer hat for someone you might know.
(cheering)
- Yes!
- She's gonna steal it from them!
- Go Packers!
- Whose is this?
- Oh, um, well this last one is made
in certain color for your logo,
- I love it!
- and it's a big afghan that I
only used my fingers for.
- What!
- Just the fingers.
- Wow.
- No hook!
- Oh my God!
Thank you, you are such a blessing!